why would i go to an award for
do i have any new music why would i show
up
and i deleted my twitter and [ __ ] cardi
b is saying goodbye to twitter again
nowadays with social media everybody
just have different opinions the
rapper's social media account is
deactivated apparently in response to
outrage from her fan base following
cardi skipping the grammy awards by all
appearances cardi's instagram account is
also nowhere to be found let's back up
when did i ever gave hints that i was
going to the [ __ ] grammys cardi
doesn't mince words in this instagram
live session on sunday speaking out
against criticism from her fans when she
didn't show up for the grammys
when did i ever gave hints that i was
going to the grammys and for you to call
me lazy because i'm not going to an
award
what
wha why would i go to an award for
do i have any new music why would i show
up with one nomination that nomination
best draft performance for her song up
and if cardi did attend the ceremony she
would have gone home empty-handed baby
keem and kendrick lamar won four family
ties so you wanted me to go to the
grammys losing a war and me just be
there it's not like
that's great that's great but the main
conflict here cardi's family and she's
not having any of it let me tell you
something i don't give a [ __ ] whatever i
said on them tweets i really
[ __ ] meaning oh why would you
wish that on somebody i'm somebody
mother well that person brought up my
son if you're talking about me why you
bringing up my
son
what do i got my son got to do with
anything if you bring up my son i hate
you as her fans might recall cardi
previously left twitter for brief
periods in 2020 and 2021 i'm doing girl
day today right and um
and i'm chilling and everything and then
i'm going to my twitter and i see people
on my twitter my fans
my own fans talking
we should also note leading up to her
twitter exit cardi allegedly continued
defending her grammy's absence tweeting
when and where did i ever give hints
like are you okay
and while teasing her new music cardi
also said next year seemingly a soft
rsvp for the grammys in 2023. i just
want to be like a party i like parties
that's cardi chatting with e.t last year
and in the lead-up to hosting the amas
she spoke out against the downside of
social media i'm always thankful when um
when i when i win an award
any award you know what i'm saying
because it's just like sometimes you
know
nowadays with social media everybody
just have different opinions and
sometimes no matter if a hundred
thousand people are saying that they
like it it could be two three people
they're saying the nasty thing and it
just like make you feel like am i doing
enough am i doing enough and like when i
get these awards you just show like like
fans
and people in the industry think that
that song is that girl
so when i get a war it's just a
confirmation like oh you that girl that
girl that's only that girl
[Music]